Ron DeSantis was sworn into office again
yesterday and he did so on the Bible of
the Revolution this Bible goes back to
1782 when the U.S Congress endorsed the
King James translation of the Aitkin
Bible which printer Robert Aitkin
published after America won the
Revolutionary War it is the first and
only Edition ever commissioned Ron
DeSantis was able to borrow this edition
of the Bible from Glenn Beck and so Ron
DeSantis takes the oath of office on
this Bible Glenn Beck lent it to him
because he believes that Ron desantis's
governorship has real historical
significance his words it is the
beginning of a renewal of the principles
for which our Founders fought this is of
course just another signal that Ron
DeSantis is running for president in
2024. his wife looked absolutely
beautiful at the swearing and DeSantis
doing all the right things to do that
and he's pulling together a coalition of
some people who really liked Trump some
people who like Glenn Beck really didn't
like Trump certainly not in 2016. it's a
signal that Ron DeSantis is just pulling
more and more support together